bonsoir mardi 27 avril bienvenue dans le
journal préparé par la rédaction de tv
78 c'est l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale voici les titres de cette édition
près de mille personnes réunies hier sur
la place de l'hôtel de ville les
rambolitains ont rendu hommage à
stéphanie aime cette fonctionnaire de
police assassiné vendredi dernier au
commissariat de la ville autour de la
famille de la victime de nombreux élus
et habitants ont fait également le
déplacement
retour sur ce rassemblement le secteur
du bâtiment subit de plein fouet la
crise des matières premières certains
matériaux comme l'acier se font de plus
en plus rares conséquence les prix
augmentent de quoi inquiéter les
professionnels reportage dans une
entreprise à méré et invités christophe
bouquin président de la fédération
française du bâtiment des yvelines et
puis à la fin de ce journal les voitures
de collection seront de sortie 25 plus
précisément qui était proposée lors
d'une vente aux enchères à versailles
c'était dimanche au domaine de madame
elisabeth on parlera également tout à
l'heure de circuits courts avec une
boutique qui a été lancé récemment à
magny les hameaux
l information du jour nous est parvenue
dans l'après midi emmanuel macron
assistera jeudi aux obsèques et de
stéphanie m et c'est une annonce de
l'elysée la fonctionnaire de police a
été tué pour rappel au commissariat de
rambouillet vendredi dernier la ville où
elle reposera n'a pas été encore révélée
autre information importante également
annoncé par l'elysée stéphanie aime
recevra un hommage national la cérémonie
se déroulera vendredi à rambouillet une
semaine donc après les faits et sera
présidée par le premier ministre jean
castex
hier déjà un hommage a été rendu devant
l'hôtel de ville à rambouillet dans la
foule des habitants venus très nombreux
mais aussi des élus du territoire et des
ministres une cérémonie qui était courte
et sobre à la demande de la famille
celliers agathe son go et justine
brasier était sur place le récit
d'astrid bergère
[Musique]
la marseillaise a résonné devant l'hôtel
de ville de rambouillet lundi 26 avril
pour rendre hommage à stéphanie m
cette fonctionnaire de police assassiné
trois jours plus tôt dans le
commissariat de la commune
des centaines d'habitants se sont
déplacés pour soutenir sa famille et ses
collègues
je suis révoltée par l'intolérance et
que et que c'est quelque chose qui m'a
choqué beaucoup parce que les enfants de
cette dame pourrait être mes petits
enfants parce que parce que je pense à
la famille qui restent et que de se
faire tuer comme ça en allant au travail
je trouve ça épouvantable
certains sont venus de plus loin en ile
de france pour dénoncer ces actes rendre
hommage mais aussi faire passer un
message
je dénonce cet acte barbare c'est une
mère de famille qui a laissé des enfants
et
je suis venu dire que l'islam c'est pas
ça l'islam c'est une religion de
tolérance de paix et de foi je ne sais
pas au nom de qui pourquoi il a tué
cette pauvre dame qui n'a rien demandé
ministre président du sénat députés
autour de la maire de rambouillet de
nombreux élus ont fait le déplacement
j'ai vu une d'abord pour rendre hommage
à stéphanie à cette personne qui a été
assassinée sauvagement cet attentat qui
a eu lieu vendredi à rambouillet pour
rendre hommage à cette personne pour
rendre hommage à ses enfants ses deux
filles et son mari parce que c'est à eux
aujourd'hui à la qui je pense
une cérémonie sobre courte à la demande
de la famille vendredi 30 avril un
hommage national sera rendu
présidée par jean castex et à la même
heure 17h30 des policiers se sont
également réunis partout en france dans
ou devant leur commissariat en hommage à
leur collègue assassiné c'était un
rassemblement à l'appel du syndicat de
police unité sgp police les derniers
chiffres du comité 19 dans le
département des yvelines sur une semaine
les données sont plutôt à la baisse mais
reste encore très élevé seule exception
le taux de positivité aux tests qui est
en légère hausse
- 49 en revanche pour le taux
d'incidence qui s'établit à 3 181 c'est
le nombre de nouveaux contaminée pour
cent mille habitants
le taux d'occupation des lits en
réanimation est quasi identique par
rapport à la semaine dernière six ans
aux patients étaient hospitalisés hier
dans les établissements du département
114 toujours placé en réanimation
et depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
mille six cent soixante dix sept
personnes sont décédées ducobu de 19
dans les hôpitaux du département et dans
le même temps la campagne de vaccination
se poursuit dans le département des
yvelines le vaccinodromes installé au
sein du vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines va même proposer
désormais des créneaux en soirée ce
vendredi ce sera une première le site
sera ouvert jusqu'à 23 heures pour
réaliser des vaccinations avec des
créneaux supplémentaires ouverts pour
les publics éligibles pour rappel la
vaccination fait partie des motifs
dérogatoire pour pouvoir se déplacer
après 19 heures il faut le faire bien
entendu
muni d'une attestation le point
d'ailleurs sur la vaccination dans le
département des yvelines au 26 avril
251 1069 personnes ont reçu une première
injection soit près de 22000 de plus
depuis le 20 avril
cette semaine environ 22 1800 rendez
vous ont été pris dans les yvelines pour
la vaccination dont près de dix sept
mille cinq cents pour une seconde
injection
et c'est peut-être une conséquence
directe de la crise sanitaire on va en
tout cas posé la question dans un
instant à mon invité le secteur du
bâtiment fait face à une crise des
matières premières conséquence les prix
augmenter le risque de pénurie plane
exemple dans cette entreprise à méré
avec eléonore sinoquet le secteur du
bâtiment est en crise depuis plusieurs
semaines les matières premières se font
rare entraînant une augmentation des
prix à méré dans entreprise de
métallerie tam
cela pose évidemment problème les sujets
que nous avons actuellement
effectivement ce sont les prix mais plus
fournisseurs qui ont augmenté en acier
du consommant de 30 à 40% en inox 70% et
en quincaillerie prix très très variés
puisque nous avons quelques roses de 10%
et quelques mois jusqu'à sa grâce à ce
prix là nous ne pouvons pas les répéter
à nos clients puisque nous avons signé
des marchés depuis six mois un an et ce
sont des prix fermes non révisables
conséquence des prix qui s'envolent le
risque de pénurie inquiète aussi le chef
d'entreprise
nous avons des produits standards que
nous ne trouverons donc on en veut
absolument puisqu'ils ne voulait faux et
nos fournisseurs nous dise si tu en veux
plus voilà nouveau friqués qui mesure la
chine et des états unis inspire
énormément de production encore
européenne et nous on subit
effectivement toute cette matière
première ou seebach qu'ils s'en vont à
l'étranger on nous a pu sur le marché
français donc effectivement on va avoir
quelques soucis cette crise des matières
premières aura des conséquences sur les
futurs chantiers
l'entrepreneur l'assurent il devra
intégrer à ses futurs contrats une
clause supplémentaire sur les prix des
matériaux
le but pour moi maintenant c'est de
revenir tous les promoteurs immobiliers
avec qui je travaille c'est que
maintenant nous allons revoir nos prix
avec un coefficient de révision nos
marges sont moins bonnes puisque le prix
matières étant plus plus important on
peut pas de revendre des conséquences
qui vont donc se répercuter sur les
clients la fédération française du
bâtiment estime qu'il n'y aura pas de
retour à la normale avant six mois et on
parle de ce sujet avec christophe vos
gains en visioconférence bonsoir vous
êtes le nouveau président de la
fédération française du bâtiment des
yvelines vous êtes à la tête d'une
entreprise d'électricité de serrurerie
et métallerie vous avez succédé à pierre
cojan pour un mandat de trois ans
j'imagine qu'il y avait meilleur
contexte peut-être pour aborder ce
mandat comment vous l'abordez justement
ce mandat est ce que c'est
de l'inquiétude autour de cette crise
justement des matières premières je la
porte on a un président de fédération et
surtout comme un chef d'entreprise
d'ailleurs général on est confronté 1
par jour donc on va on a celui là et
qu'il appuie déjà avant mon prédécesseur
la la très bien affronter et puis à mon
tour de le suivre mais notre quotidien
les difficultés
c'est le rôle d'âge et la reprise dans
le sujet précédent on a entendu parler
de cette crise des matières premières au
travers des pénuries qui peuvent se
présenter pour l'acier quels sont les
autres matériaux qui sont concernés
justement par cette crise c'est vrai que
le toutou les matériaux le pvc le bois
le verre
son impact est lourdement par deux
choses d'une part l' le wiki en train de
s'envoler et ensuite par un manque de
forme de deux produits qui est
aujourd'hui et est dramatique pour nos
activités on n'arrive plus à fournir
c'est aujourd'hui très compliqué pour
les entreprises de s'approvisionner en
fabriquer et fournir nos clients et
comme première conséquence on l'a vu
dans leurs reportages précédents aussi
une flambée des prix + 30% sur l'acier
ça concerne aussi par exemple le bois de
construction et l'aller les prix ont
explosé
les eaux sont de l'ordre de 200 à 250 %
c'est ça c'est ça exactement la chine et
les états unis viennent se servir sur le
marché français des bois est aujourd'hui
l'une pas on n'arrive plus à
s'approvisionner et d'autre part en plus
ça se raréfient et ensemble ça c'est
l'une des explications effectivement la
ruée sur les stocks européens qui sont
pourtant limité de pays comme la chine
les etats unis qui ont connu une forte
croissance fin 2020 d'autres
explications peut être aussi la crise
sanitaire qui en est une autre
l'échantillon repris brutalement on va
dire un rythme normal après plusieurs
mois à fonctionner au ralenti
ça pue peut-être d organiser les
filières de réapprovisionnement
également le bâtiment a pas eu la chance
de repartir relativement huit ans l'a
très vite mis en place les règles de
sécurité qui ont été mises en place par
l'oppbtp et validé par le gouvernement
entre on a quand même pu redémarrer très
rapidement un mois et demi au roi moins
bons mois en mois et demi deux mois on
est opérationnel nos équipes en étaient
formidables les ont suivis d'une manière
vraiment professionnel toutes celles qui
ont été mises en vente en place autant
pour leur production que la position de
la collection aux clients le bâtiment se
plaint quand même pas trop aujourd'hui
on a un fonctionnement est qui et qui
tourne plutôt bien on a redémarré en été
dans les premiers à redémarrer
de ce côté là on peut pas se plaindre
price a eu un impact 1 toutes ces règles
sanitaires ou bien la pac sur nos prix
entre 5 et 10% si c'était n'importe
n'importe pas puisque les gels même et
tout le monde a joué le jeu tout ou non
salariaux et à la hauteur de 200
sécurité et j'ajoute que donald trump ne
serait pas aussi étranger à cette crise
et matières premières puisque lorsqu'il
était à la tête du pouvoir aux états
unis l'a fortement taxé le bois canadien
conséquence on disait tout à l'heure
rues et des états unis les entreprises
américaines sur les stocks européens
avec des achats au prix à des prix plus
élevés ce qui pourrait expliquer aussi
cette crise des matières premières
risque hull le blocage aussi pendant
plusieurs jours du canal de suez a plus
avoir un impact négatif sur sur cette
crise notamment sur le prix du fret
maritime
évidemment on a du mal à notre échelle
du département
de s'en rendre compte mais nationalement
nous le faire remonter effectivement
forcément c'est on va le subir
et forcément on va le répercuter sur nos
vies jusqu à quel moment parce que le
souci c'est bon là beaucoup de devis qui
ont été signés et qui ont été validés
avec des prix est aujourd'hui le
matériel pour la chaîne n'a plus rien à
voir avec cela et c'est là où on demande
au gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est aussi
aux négociations de ça parce que on peut
très bien faire fonctionner nos
entreprises et à la fin est obligé de
les fermer par un problème qui est celui
de ce montant de fournitures qui dépasse
les achats dû réguler dans l'étude du
départ donc c'est de s'adapter
finalement à la fluctuation des prix
pour que les marges ne soit pas trop ne
subissent pas trop de conséquence
finalement ce que les marges sont revues
à la baisse justement avec ce prix des
matières premières qui augmente
exactement à l'est les matières
premières nous nous plombe complètement
notre exercice
et puis bah je vous ai parlé aussi du
côté sanitaire devrait être de tous et
c'est vrai que des pluies qui ont été
réalisés il ya un an aujourd'hui les
mettre en application ce long chantier
c'est plus que faux billets c'est limite
mais des fois à se repositionner dessus
comment oser prix risque de pénurie est
ce que ça veut dire que les entreprises
aujourd'hui pourrait être contrainte de
stopper des chantiers dans les mois à
venir
et du coup pas d'engendrer justement
d'aider retard sur ces chantiers est ce
que c'est un risque aujourd'hui qui est
irréelle mais je pense que c'est plus
que qu'un risque en toute façon l'année
on est confronté à faire tourner nos
entreprises donc fabriqué à perte et
faire travailler à perdre je pense que
c'est plus qu'un risque
il va falloir vraiment que
on soit entendue est bon qu'on nous
écoute sur ça parce que comment un jeune
fabrice peut arriver à faire tomber son
chantier en sachant qu'ils perdent de
l'argent tous les jours c'est déjà pas
évident quand tout va bien et là c'est
impossible vous en parliez tout à
l'heure ça c'est nécessité de geler les
pénalités de retard c'est l'une des
demandes de la ffb au niveau national au
ministre de l'économie bien évidemment
bien évidemment c'est primordial
aujourd'hui des sur les marchés au
public saut sur les marchés privés
ça va faire partie aussi c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué mais c'est vrai que
vitale pour l'entreprise c'est le
principal dossier sur lequel vous allez
vous atteler là sur les premiers mois de
votre mandat
ben il est vrai que on est là pour
accompagner nos nos entreprises
s'affairent maintenant qu'on est en
plein en plein dedans et là on a cette
fédération qui a été magnifique
formidable depuis un an qui fonctionne
qui a été vraiment fédératrice qui a
permis à tout le monde ce souvenir sur
les visions on connaissait pas trop dans
le bâtiment parce qu'on était quand même
plus amenés à se rencontrer sur place
mais depuis un an les visions n'arrête
pas et ont permis à tout le monde d'être
entouré de se libérer et tous les des
solutions à tous ces problèmes
merci pressenti mais on va continuer ce
travail là effectivement merci fait ça
vous vient d'avoir été avec nous merci à
vous les jours après les efforts
président nouvellement élu de la
fédération française du bâtiment la
fédération dans les yvelines
dans le reste de l'actualité les
derniers chiffres du chômage dans les
yvelines
sur le premier trimestre 2010 21 le
nombre de demandeurs d'emplois a diminué
est de 1,9 pour cent par rapport à la
fin de l'année dernière il s'agit de la
catégorie à c'est-à-dire des personnes
sans aucune activité
en revanche si l'on regarde les
statistiques sur un an le show demain le
chômage a augmenté de plus de 7 % entre
mars 2020 et mars 2021 dans le
département une hausse supérieure à la
moyenne nationale qui est à 6,3 pour
cent au chapitre politique les élections
régionales qui se tiendront les 20 et 27
juin prochain ce mardi le parti de la
république en marche a dévoilé les noms
de ses têtes de liste par département
pour le scrutin dans les yvelines la
candidature en visible de france sera
mené par jean noël barrot député de la
2e circonscription
celui qui est également secrétaire
général du modem alliés du parti
présidentiel sera accompagné d'horreur
bergé la députée de la 10e
circonscription est inscrite en numéro 2
sur la liste yvelinoise au niveau
régional pour rappel la candidature
éconduite par laurent saint martin qui
fera face à la présidente sortante
valérie pécresse à clémentine autain
pour la france insoumise et julien bayou
pour europe ecologie les verts audrey
pulvar pour le parti socialiste et
jordan bardella avec le rassemblement
national à magny les hameaux le
collectif la clairière paysanne a lancé
sa propre boutique installée directement
dans une ferme et grâce à une vente en
circuits courts les quatre amis à
l'origine du projet espèrent séduire de
nombreux clients et mélanie poker et joe
sakal le collectif la clairière paysanne
s'est installé à magny les hameaux dans
les yvelines avec un projet ouvrir un
point de vente directe sans
intermédiaire au sein de leur ferme la
ferme de la closeraie alors pour cela
les quatre amis s'organisent
chacun chacune à un atelier de
prédilection donc mathilde ça va être
les herbes médicinales et aromatiques
marc albert et moi ce sera le maraîchage
et alban ce sont les arbres fruitiers et
fourragers chacun chacune à une
casquette avec un terrain de 2 5
hectares ils cultivent leurs produits
selon un cahier des charges agriculture
biologique
l'idée de
de planter à la fois des arbres à côté
des légumes à côté des aromatiques à
côté des petits fruits
c'est essayer de recréer un équilibre
naturel et d'apporter le plus de
biodiversité possible de recréer
les fermes d'antan de polyculture
élevage ou hutus s'harmonisaient
colocataires sur la ferme avec berger et
maraîchers la boutique ouverte depuis le
6 mars propose viande yaourt miel laine
et légumes en plus de la vente aux amap
cette boutique était un objectif de base
c'est vraiment notre particularité dans
cette boutique c'est que ces issues de
nos productions et de seul élément
la laboratoire transformation qui est
juste là pour les yaourts
on a tous le stockage pour les légumes
que juste derrière dans le regard les
produits comprend retrouver ici
ces deux produits bannis quoi et bien
évidemment après seulement quelques
semaines d'ouverture le nouveau point de
vente attire les clients du conte les
produits locaux
ces produits localement avec des
produits pain qui nous semble de
meilleure qualité que les produits
industriels les premiers légumes de la
ferme arriveront au mois de juin
en attendant la boutique reste ouvert
tous les samedis de 10 heures à 13
heures la situation reste tendue à
trappes dans la nuit de lundi à mardi le
commissariat de police a été de nouveau
visé par des tirs de mortiers d'artifice
c'est la troisième fois depuis jeudi
l es faits se sont produits vers minuit
avec une quinzaine de tyrans tour
recensés vers 23 heures c'est le centre
de rétention administrative de plaisir
qui avait été à cibler également par
plusieurs personnes
aucune interpellation n'a eu lieu pour
le moment selon le syndicat sgp police
66 fed attaque au mortier projectiles
contre les policiers ont été
enregistrées dans les yvelines et ce
depuis début avril et direction
versailles à présent une vente aux
enchères de véhicules de collection
était organisée ce dimanche le rendez
vous était précédée d'une exposition au
domaine de madame elisabeth avec les 25
voitures concernées le reportage de
mickaël landreau
ferrari porsche aston martin range-rover
des modèles rares étaient exposés au
domaine de madame elisabeth à versailles
ce week end les 25 et 26 avril une
exposition gratuite organisée dans le
cadre d'une vente aux enchères au rendez
vous a attiré plusieurs milliers
d'amoureux de belles mécaniques
avide de nostalgie
il ya une belle range rover là bas qui
est très jolie qui me rappelle mon
enfance les années 80 et a que des vieux
véhicules donc oui faut oui oui ça rend
nostalgique
la petite 205 gti invite 6/4 jeune
j'avais une 205 gti et 8,9 sur laquelle
j'ai appris à conduire en fait ça parle
au coeur tout à fait au total 25
véhicules de collection étaient
présentés au public avant la vente
il ya un peu de tout on essaye d'avoir
aussi un parc automobile assez assez
mélangé dans le sens où il ya pour tous
les prix pour toutes les envies pour
tous les goûts surtout il ya autant de
d'anciennes et de très anciennes notre
première vient 2000 date de 1947 mais
également de youngtimers avec des
collectors des futurs connector qui ne
sont pas encore les voitures de
collection la bmw z3 où la porsche 996
qui va forcément trouvé preneur à des
petits prix
après l'exposition place à la vente ce
dimanche 26 avril toujours à versailles
dans cette maison de vente aux enchères
une trentaine d'acheteurs s'est déplacé
s'est laissé tenter la plupart des 25
lots sont partis ça a été même au delà
nos espérances avec un très beau look
s'est vendu l'aston martin dbs qui est
parti pour 142 mille euros marteau
auxquels il faut rajouter 20 % de frais
donc c'est une très grande surprise pour
les vendeurs comme pour nous on est très
heureux
les autres lots sont bien partis
notamment sur internet et aussi des
acheteurs en salle donc finalement là la
pandémie n'a pas n'a pas complètement
stoppé les ventes aux enchères
cette maison de vente organisera
d'autres ventes aux enchères de
véhicules de collection le prochain
rendez vous est programmé le 5 juillet
prochain toujours à versailles
après une édition 2009 1 a annulé lors
de la 18ème prairial la 18e préval avait
été annulée de montigny-le-bretonneux
l'année dernière elle s'est tenu
finalement 1 ce week-end à la ferme du
manège il s'agit d'un rendez vous annuel
pour collecter des fonds en faveur de la
lutte contre la cécité avec le
financement de chiens guides d'aveuglés
une édition remaniée par le lion's club
de montigny les trois villages avec 21
exposants pas de produits du terroir et
de restauration covit 19 oblige mais les
visiteurs ont répondu tout de même
présent en battant les chiffres de
fréquentation précédent 3500 sont venus
partager leur passion pour les plantes
et les fleurs les propos recueillis par
mélanie poker
nous sommes donc une association un club
service qui travaillons pour différentes
actions et entre autres la cécité et
donc c'est important puisque cette année
nous avons remis un chèque de 5000 euros
lors de l'inauguration pour donc une
bientôt à chiens complet donc c'est très
important
j'ai parlé aussi des exposants puisque
il y à de nombreux exposants qui n'avait
pu participer à aucun marché dans les
yvelines
un événement qui on l'a compris a aussi
vocation de garder du lien en cette
période compliquée c'était aussi
l'objectif de ce tournoi 10 portes
samedi dernier la ville des mureaux
s'est associé à even to give pour le
proposer une soixantaine de joueurs
s'étaient affrontés retour avec mélanie
poké et on est sur les dernières
secondes de ce tournoi et vocale et ses
terres
mi mai ils sont les vainqueurs du et les
mixed game challenge évoqua ai dit qu'on
remporte le premier tournoi en ligne des
mureaux la ville proposait cinq heures
de compétition autour du jeu rouquette
league
c'est comme un match de foot mais avec
des voitures donc les voitures doivent
mettre le ballon dans
dans les buts voilà donc ça se joue en
équipe de deux ou de trois donc là on a
décidé de le faire en équipe de deux
parce que c'est vrai que trois c'est
plus difficile pour les pour les jeunes
de trouver trois coéquipiers il s'agit
d'un jeu qui est multiplateforme et
gratuit donc tous les joueurs peuvent
participer donc si une personne un pc ou
l'autre une xbox ils peuvent se
rencontrer donc participer au tournoi
des matchs de cinq minutes en
élimination directe pour les 32 équipes
inscrites pour ce challenge
la ville souhaitait garder du lien et
que ses habitants en cette période de
qu'ovide avant on faisait des tournois
esport on ad on a un parc de consoles
donc on faisait des tourneries sport
dans des salles et l'idée c'était de
pouvoir continuer cette activité mais
chacun chez soi pour que voilà il n'y a
pas de risque de transmission donc
chacun peut rester chez soit
de nombreux lots ont été partagés entre
les participants les vainqueurs vont
recevoir des casque gaming la ville
envisage de proposer d'autres tournois
il se porte
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]